bonjour le robinet merci beaucoup d'être
notre invité politique ce matin merde de
Reims d'horizon le parti d'Édouard
Philippe et président de la Fédération
hospitalière de France on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet
Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour
on va évidemment parler puisque vous
êtes président de la Fédération
hospitalière de la situation à l'hôpital
entre la bronchiolite la grippe la 9e
vague de covid c'est un cocktail
explosif pour l'hôpital public est-ce
que l'hôpital est prêt l'hôpital est
sous tension nous avons une augmentation
de la l'épidémie de la covid 45000 cas
supplémentaires en une journée plus de
25% d'hospitalisation dans les hôpitaux
depuis une semaine ça vous rajoutez la
bronchiolite plus 25% d'hospitalisation
également plus la grippe qui arrive
plutôt que prévu avec un virus assez
virulent cette année donc oui le
cocktail il est explosif aujourd'hui
sous tension ça veut dire quoi qu'il y
aura des déprogrammations que il y a des
patients qui ne pourront pas être
soignés alors c'est d'ailleurs les
conséquences du plan blanc ou du plan
orsenn qui avait été annoncé par le
ministre de la Santé et chaque semaine
des hôpitaux annoncent leur plan blanc
donc ce qui veut dire qui est une
réquisition bien évidemment d'agent
hospitaliers quand on dirait acquisition
ça peut être aussi un rappel lors des
congés ça peut être des transferts
d'agents d'infirmiers d'être soignants
d'un service à Arnaud avec la
conséquence que l'on connaît possibilité
de déprogrammation et donc de non prise
en charge à 100 de patients et nous
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire citoyen ici
est-ce qu'il faut se remettre à porter
le masque est-ce qu'il faut relancer la
vaccination est-ce qu'il y a des actions
qu'il faudrait mener dès maintenant pour
prévenir bien évidemment et d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'appelle la FHF c'est donner
la possibilité pourquoi pas notamment
Homer d'instaurer le port du masque
notamment dans les transports en commun
il suffit de prendre le métro à Paris et
on est tellement bondés les uns contre
les autres donc ça facilite la
transmission du virus et surtout une
campagne d'appel pour se faire vacciner
aujourd'hui il n'y a que 10% de la
population une question cible qui s'est
fait vacciner contre la covine notamment
ce fameux 4e rappel un gros retard sur
la grippe gros retard sur la grippe
moins 20% par rapport à l'année dernière
donc oui il appelle c'est
protégeons-nous protégeons également les
autres et donc le port du masque quand
cela est nécessaire dans les transports
en commun et bien évidemment la vaccès
au gouvernement il faut le retour du
masque obligatoire notamment dans les
transports et dans les lieux fermés je
pense que ce serait en tout cas
salutaire je crois qu'on ne peut pas
attendre on les fait de fin d'année vont
arriver on sait ce qui apporte les fêtes
de fin d'année ce qui est normal un
brassage de la population dans les
magasins
en famille donc oui le port du masque
pour moi est une nécessité dans les
lieux clos les lieux bondés les
transports en commun
sinon laissez la possibilité aux maires
mais rapidement à quelle échéance il
faudrait que ça se fasse dans les jours
qui viennent dans la semaine qui qui
arrivent parce que
les fêtes arrivent et donc oui c'est une
nécessité vous savez il faut mieux
prévenir que guérir et malheureusement
notre cible de santé est souvent géré
avec des mesures d'urgence et donc ça
veut dire que les leçons n'ont pas été
tirées de cette crise covid qui dure
depuis près de trois ans maintenant
alors je dirais pas ça parce que le
gouvernement a fait un sombre d'annonce
qu'ils vont dans le sens de ce que
demandait la Fédération hospitalière de
France notamment sur la question des
financements de l'hôpital public sur la
question de la revalorisation des
astreintes et des gardes dans les
urgences donc le gouvernement a entendu
et entend sauf qu'on réagit encore une
fois à l'urgence et donc ce que nous
demandons nous c'est un plan pluriel
pour avoir une visibilité pour avoir la
possibilité je demande d'établir des
plans sur plusieurs années rassurer le
Ségur était une bonne chose là il y a le
CNR santé le CNR santé nous disons
attention le constat il est partagé le
diagnostic est partagé par l'ensemble
les acteurs du monde de la santé et par
les usagers et les citoyens il faut des
actions rapides mais le vrai sujet de
l'hôpital public comme le sujet du
système de santé dans sa globalité c'est
le problème des ressources humaines et
le problème du recrutement de
l'attractivité des carrières
hospitalières alors le recrutement
l'attractivité passe par une
revalorisation des salaires mais pas que
il y a d'autres leviers actionnés
lesquels par exemple mais bien
évidemment vous avez entièrement raison
c'est sûr que la rémunération est en
fait et c'est vrai que quand on compare
ces salaires dans la fonction publique
hospitalière et dans le privé il y a une
nette différence mais ce n'est pas que
cela c'est aussi le bien-être au travail
c'est aussi s'adapter aux désirs et aux
volonté des nouveaux profils de santé et
donc il y a véritablement de spécifiques
par rapport aujourd'hui on va être très
clair c'est vrai que le médecin ou
l'infirmière ou l'aide-soignante qui est
dévoué corps et âme s'est terminée
aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a aussi
l'équilibre avec la vie professionnelle
une génération qui est passée voilà
c'est donc il faut aussi s'adapter il
faut entendre aussi c'est ces désirs
d'équilibre entre la vie professionnelle
et la vie personnelle donc il faut que
l'on puisse mener une campagne
d'attractivité une campagne de
recrutement sera la FHF lors de santé
l'hôpital c'est pas lui-même si la
branche sur laquelle était assise je
m'explique à force de dire que tout
allait mal que c'était catastrophique
que les conditions de travail étaient
très dégradées est-ce qu'on a pas
repoussé en fait une jeune génération
qui pouvait s'intéresser aux métiers de
la santé et qui finalement ont pu
tellement envie d'y aller en disant oh
là là alors pourquoi je souris par
rapport à ce que vous venez de dire
parce que c'est exactement le discours
que j'ai tenu lors de la dernière
réunion de la FHF en disant attention au
discours que l'on peut tenir ce n'est
pas aussi on est un discours
catastrophique que l'on va attirer des
jeunes dans les carrières hospitalières
l'hôpital est en tension bien évidemment
il y a des sujets extrêmement importants
mais derrière il faut que nous-mêmes
nous fassions la promotion de l'hôpital
la promotion des carrières hospitalières
ce sont des métiers fantastiques de
l'administratif de la technique jusqu'à
soignant médical ou paramédical ce sont
de belles et grandes carrières que l'on
peut faire lorsqu'on est à l'hôpital
public mais attention le système de
santé ne doit pas reposer uniquement sur
l'hôpital s'il y a une réforme
nécessaire elle ne doit pas être une
réforme hospitale au centre c'est
l'ensemble du système qui doit être
réformer et je pense notamment la
médecine de ville avec une meilleure
coordination on a l'impression que c'est
un peu un serpent de mer l'histoire de
la coordination
des exemples qui fonctionnent je donne
un exemple celui que je connais le mieux
au CHU de Reims avec la maison médicale
de garde une coordination entre la
médecine de ville et généraliste et
l'hôpital notamment alors j'aime pas le
terme de tri quand on parle des urgences
mais de l'orientation de réorientation
c'est un système qui fonctionne
aujourd'hui qu'il faut développer sur
l'ensemble du territoire donc faisons
confiance aussi au territoire les
médecins libéraux qui seront en grève
jeudi et vendredi prochain ils demandent
une hausse de leur tarifs ils ont raison
vous savez moi j'appelle on le vient de
dire que la situation était critique
pour l'hôpital public je rappelle que
l'hôpital accueille 85 % des patients
covid alors que l'hôpital dans une
station normale représente 60% de
l'activité moi j'appelle à une
solidarité en cette période compliquée
et difficile pour l'hôpital public et
donc j'appelle nos amis médecins
généralistes comme SOS médeca ou autre
je veux dire peut-être à lever leur
grève et aller vers la négociation parce
que là c'est le système de santé qui est
en danger dans les jours qui viennent il
y a une autre question qui est dans le
débat en ce moment c'est la
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
est-ce que pour vous il faut les
réintégrer malheureusement
ce à quoi on a assisté la semaine
dernière à l'Assemblée nationale on a
bien vu que c'était un débat plus
politique que sanitaire je considère que
ce n'est pas forcément parlementaire de
ce de prendre en charge cette question
mais attendons la vie de lâche has
pardon qui doit donner un avis dans les
jours ou les semaines ça doit être une
décision scientifique ou politique
scientifiques et pour moi à leur dire le
débat n'a même pas lieu d'être vous
savez il y a 1,2 millions d'agents dans
nos hôpitaux établissements médicaux
sociaux
donc ça fait en terme de pourcentage
c'est 0,0 voilà et derrière ça si on
prend les infirmiers ou infirmières qui
sont plus de 600000 à l'hôpital public
ça représente 500 infirmiers ou
infirmières donc le débat n'a pas lieu
d'être ce ne doit pas être un débat
politique c'est une question d'éthique
une question de santé publique moi je
pense surtout aux agences hospitaliers
qui ont fait la démarche de ce vacciner
c'est-à-dire 99% et qui aujourd'hui sont
en situation difficile étendue mais ce
serait même ce serait même ce serait
même une mesure enfin contre intuitive
ou la présidente de la commerce par
exemple dit il faut pas faut pas
réintégrer les soignants non vaccinés
parce que parce que pour tous ceux qui
ont été vaccinés ça donnerait le message
qu'en fait tout tout ça la servi à rien
évidemment et dans une équipe lorsque
vous allez avoir des agents hospitaliers
créer des tensions qui peut créer des
tensions c'est un mauvais signal et un
mauvais signe que l'on donne à
l'ensemble de l'agence hospitalier qui
ont fait la démarche de se vacciner mais
la vaccination n'est pas sujet de
nouveau à l'hôpital et les vaccinations
obligatoires quand on hospitalier moi
j'étais hospitalier j'ai dû me faire
vacciner par rapport contre un
saintondre de maladie ou de virus ou
est-ce qu'il faut rendre la vaccination
obligatoire contre la grippe alors ça
c'est un sujet qui m'a toujours toujours
intéressé et lorsque j'étais hospital au
universitaire de moi quand j'exerçais je
me suis posé la question déjà savoir
pourquoi la vaccin contre la grippe
n'est pas obligatoire pour les soignants
il faut pour vous je pense que le débat
mérite d'être sur la table oui et la
triple épidémie en cours pourrait
pourrait pourrait pousser à prendre ce
type de décision je pense que c'est
cette triple épidémie peut être
l'occasion justement de reparler des
obligations que l'on a lorsqu'on
travaille en établissement de santé
sur la question des déserts médicaux
parce j'ai l'impression qu'il a des
divergences entre horizons et François
Brune le ministre de la Santé lui il
veut pas de coercition vous qu'elle est
votre position il faut de la coercition
sur cette question des zones sous dotées
pour obliger les médecins à s'y
installer alors c'est un débat que nous
avons au sein d'horizon et notamment
avec Thomas Meunier bien évidemment et
avec Agnès Firmin le Bodo moitié titre
personnel je ne suis pas pour la
coercition on a eu plusieurs exemples
dans certains pays européens qui ont
montré que cela n'a pas fonctionné en
Allemagne notamment en Allemagne donc
oui c'est facile de proposer la
coercition c'est facile de poser de
parler de d'obligation je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit la solution c'est un
message pour votre groupe aussi oui mais
on a eu ce débat de façon totalement
transparente on a eu ce débat au sein du
bureau d'horizon justement et c'est ça
l'intérêt la partie politique aussi de
pouvoir échanger de pouvoir dialoguer de
d'échanger sur ses positions ce débat
existe aussi dans les parties parce
qu'il y a un ras-le-bol les élus locaux
il y a une grosse pression en fait qui
ont eux-mêmes les élus locaux qui ont
eux-mêmes la pression de leurs
administrer et qui disent il faut
trouver une solution et allons-y sur la
coercition j'ai participé
le système de santé lors du dernier
congrès du Salon des mers de l'AMF et
c'est vrai que ce sujet dernière est
revenu sur la révolution à table et
beaucoup des locaux
et beaucoup de délu ruraux notamment
sont pour cette coercition et cette
obligation je crois que c'est assez
partagé mais je crois que la tendance
tirait vers la non obligation on
va parler oui vous écrivez que dans une
tribune dans Le Monde la France ne sera
pas une nation verte tant que son
système de santé ne sera pas durable
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer un
petit peu ce que ce que vous aviez en
tête oui parce que le système de santé a
un rôle extrêmement important et doit
s'engager également dans cette objet
c'est ça alors il y a des choses qui se
font sur les territoires il y a de
multiples exemples mais il faut avoir
conscience que 8% des émissions des gaz
à effet de serre proviennent du système
de santé en général 700000 tonnes de
déchets produits par l'hôpital
et par jour hospitalisé et donc on le
voit bien il y a l'industrie également
du médicament que l'on intègre dans le
bien évidemment dans le système de santé
et donc bien évidemment que si on veut
aller beaucoup plus loin le système de
santé dans sa globalité doit non pas
faire un pas mais prendre des mesures
ambitieuses c'est l'objectif que nous
portons avec la FHF nous avons fait des
propositions je l'ai remis au ministre
de la santé et à la ministre délégué et
à la première ministre également et on
le voit dans les territoires les
établissements font innove prennent des
décisions justement pour en termes
d'énergie en termes de tri de déchets en
termes d'utilisation de la blague c'est
que on a vu qu'avec la période covid par
exemple on s'est mis à consommer des
masques en plastique comme des dingues
et on en retrouve partout dans la mer
etc c'est hyper polluant est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y a des alternatives ce qui
a des possibilités est-ce qu'il y a des
solutions par rapport ce genre de choses
alors on a vu quelques initiatives en
concernant les fameux masques c'est vrai
qui qu'on le retrouvait un peu partout
la pollution elle a été la pollution
était massive avec l'utilisation des
masques
certaines entreprises locales avec les
hôpitaux l'établissement mis en place
notamment la question de la collecte des
masques que la collecte des déchets le
tri parfois la retrans la transformation
des du matériel donc oui il faut aller
dans ce sens et moi je crois que et j'en
suis sûr que l'ensemble des responsables
établissements de santé sanitaire comme
médico-sociaux et le monde de la santé
est engagé dans cette démarche vertueuse
nécessité qui fait le lien entre les
élus et les l'environnement l'écologie
puisque les députés vont examiner à
partir de la semaine prochaine le projet
de loi pour le développement des
énergies renouvelables est-ce que vous
vous êtes favorable à un droit de veto
des mers c'est ce que vont redemandez
les députés les républicains alors oui
alors on le voit dans les territoires je
prends notamment toujours le cas que je
connais le département de la Marne avec
nos inscriptions patrimoine à l'Unesco
avec tous ces projets de développement
des armées renouvelables l'éolien
notamment mais il y a aussi la
métallisation qui pose aussi quelques
difficultés pour les riverains il y a la
question également des panneaux
photovoltaïques je pense qu'il est
important que les maires les élus locaux
dans leur globalité puissent donner leur
avis et donner leur avis ou avoir le
dernier mot et aussi avoir le droit
d'avoir et aussi avoir le dernier mot je
pense que c'est important il faut de la
concertation vous savez sur ce sujet les
élus locaux ont bien compris une chose
c'est que il va falloir et notamment
avec la crise que nous traversons
aujourd'hui et le coût de l'énergie
je n'ai pas pu l'accompagner pour des
raisons d'agenda mais j'ai bien
évidemment suivi la séquence du Pré en
horizon au salon des mers qu'est-ce
qu'il venait chercher en fait non mais
je savais Édouard Philippe il est avant
tout ça toujours été un élu local il est
maire du Havre la DN d'horizon a été le
parti des maires même si bien sûr le
parti ne doit pas être uniquement une
formation politique qui rassemble des
élus mais aussi des citoyens mais on
sait très bien qu'avec le nom cumul des
mandats les maires ont été aussi
éloignés du débat national et donc
Horizon a été là pour proposer justement
de réintégrer les maires dans le débat
national
Macron qu'ils ont été éloignés national
non non la vraie raison a été le nom
cumul des mandats après avec Emmanuel
Macron on a eu une évolution ça a été
compliqué au début du précédent
quinquennat il faut être clair il faut
savoir le dire il faut le dire la crise
de la covid a été un accélérateur je
dirais de cette prise en compte des mers
notamment avec l'instauration de ce duo
mer préfet qui a fonctionné sur les
territoires il continuer à voir ce
dialogue avec les représentants
un retour sur la loi sur le non-cumul
des mandats et à revenir à la situation
d'avant vous étiez député maire alors ça
vous manque bien sûr que parfois on est
un peu frustré mais j'ai fait le choix
de rester maire de rare donc ça je ne le
regrette pas mais par contre on peut
avoir une forme de frustration en même
temps aujourd'hui vous êtes aussi
vice-président de la région Grand Est
alors non je ne suis plus vite
depuis ma prise de fonction la FHF j'ai
démissionne de mon poste de
vice-président mais c'est vrai que sur
des sujets vous savez moi je suis un
sujet qui il y a la santé bien sûr qui
me passionne j'ai un autre sujet
d'actualité qui me passionne puisque
j'étais le référent pour mon ancienne
formation politique lorsque c'est
parlementaire c'est le sujet des
retraites par exemple et donc c'est vrai
que parfois lorsque vous êtes un délu
local vous n'avez plus la possibilité de
vous exprimer sur ce sujet ou d'apporter
votre pierre à l'édifice vous exprimez
sur les retraites bien évidemment mais
moi ma position elle est claire elle
rejoint aussi celle d'Edouard Philippe
et d'horizon c'est il faut travailler
plus bien évidemment mais avec une
réforme une quand même une réforme juste
avec la prise en compte des carrières
longues et également de la pénibilité et
la FHF justement aura des propositions à
faire dans le cadre des carrières des
agents hospitaliers bien évidemment
entre Emmanuel c'est une réforme donc
paramétrique c'est soit le recul de
l'âge des par la retraite ou
l'augmentation de la durée de cotisation
Édouard Philippe avait parlé de 67 ans
mais je pense que c'était justement
mais 64 ça vous dira est-ce horizon
votre a une réforme à 64 ans sera
derrière le gouvernement sur cette
réforme des retraites même si le
gouvernements de la réforme des
républicains mais je ne connais pas la
réforme de républicain et j'ai entendu
les débats des trois candidats j'ai
l'impression que à certains nombre
d'entre eux notamment 2 sur 3 refusent
le recul d'Alger par la retraite et
considère qu'aujourd'hui il ne faut pas
emmener les Français vers un travail
plus longtemps j'ai l'impression que les
républicains sur ce sujet reviennent sur
les positions historiques ont été les
nôtres
mais j'ai entendu Aurélien Pradier qui
lui est sur une autre position
écoutez on va atteindre les 1000 comités
locaux donc qui ce comité locaux donc ça
veut dire mille communes donc ce qui
veut dire qu'il y a à peu près une à peu
près 1000 mètres puisque les mers sont
aussi les fers de lance de ces comités
locaux il y a aujourd'hui plus de 20000
adhérents pour un parti qui a un an
d'existence nous en sommes plutôt
satisfaits nous continuons à mener une
campagne d'adhésion sur le terrain parce
que comme je disais faut pas que horizon
soit uniquement à partie d'élus ça doit
pas être le Rotary club comme certains
ont aimé le dire dans la majorité non
horizon tu n'es pas ça c'est aussi à
partir constituée de citoyens de
militants qui se réunissent
régulièrement sur des sujets la retraite
sur l'éducation et ça va aux élections
Arnaud Robinet les prochaines élections
ce sont les sénatoriales est-ce qu'il y
aura des listes horizons est-ce que vous
ambitionnez un groupe horizon ici bien
évidemment vous savez je reprends la
phrase d'Édouard Philippe
horizon n'est pas là pour beurrer les
tartines bien évidemment quand on crée
un parti politique pour avoir des élus
et l'objectif est d'avoir un groupe au
Sénat nous travaillons actuellement avec
les responsables d'horizons en charge
des élections notamment Pierre-Yves
Bournazel sur ces fameuses sanatoriales
de septembre prochain dans chaque
département il y aura des discussions
avec nos partenaires de la majorité
S et candidats ensemble il y aura des
candidats horizons mais ce qui serait
logique et normale je rappelle que
Horizon est un parti de la majorité
présidentielle à partie loyale mais
libre et bien évidemment que l'objectif
est d'avoir des listes avec nos amis de
Renaissance et du MoDem ce serait j'irai
la logique des choses c'est quoi
l'objectif ça vous aurez des élus mais
combien aujourd'hui sache que vous visez
l'objectif c'est d'avoir un groupe au
Sénat bien évidemment et à certains une
année on aurait eu la possibilité
d'avoir un groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale d'avoir un comité des mers
d'avoir un groupe au Sénat donc voilà à
partie qui avait vraiment pris son envol
vous espérez bénéficier de la présidence
des républicains en clair est-ce que si
Eric Ciotti est élu vous allez appeler
les la tendance plutôt modérée des
républicains à rejoindre horizon moi je
n'ai pas de langue de bois oui bien
évidemment et on le voit aujourd'hui un
certain nombre d'élus qui sont encore
étiqueter l'air ou qui appartiennent à
la cette formation politique commence à
regarder vers horizon bien évidemment
parce que il est vrai que la position
députée qui viennent déjà vers vous
alors moi je le vois sur les élus locaux
principalement des mers des conseillers
régionaux des conseillers départementaux
des adjoints en tout cas qui aujourd'hui
voient cette évolution des républicains
et notamment avec la victoire probable
et annoncée d'érections
et qui regardent de manière très très
forte on va dire ce qui se passe chez
Horizon vous êtes en train de nous dire
que la poutre est encore en train de
travailler et bien évidemment ça fait un
moment qu'elle travaille la poutre ça
fait un moment mais vous savez la vie
politique française elle le met du temps
à évoluer on a eu un accélération avec
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 et
après on a vu que les anciens partis
parce qu'on appelle les parties de
l'Ancien Monde certains ont résisté plus
que d'autres mais on voit que cela
commence encore à évoluer et je pense
que ce qui va se passer ce week-end va
participer à la reconstitution de la vie
politique au sens de la République
sur une implosion on le voit bien
aujourd'hui je prends le président de la
région Grand Est Jean Rottner qui a
annoncé lui-même que le parti était
quasi mort était en grande difficulté
moi je l'ai dit depuis depuis longtemps
vous savez moi le point marquant était
en 2017 quand le président des
républicains n'a pas fait le choix entre
Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen et un
parti qui se dit républicain au sens
noble du terme à partie qui se dit
gaulliste ne peut pas mettre Marine Le
Pen et Emmanuel Macron au même niveau
Laurent pour être le futur candidat des
républicains en 2027 qu'est-ce que vous
en dites oui alors après là je n'ai pas
à me prononcer en tout cas si série ce
qui est élu il a annoncé clairement que
le candidat serait Laurent Wauquiez mais
je ne doute pas aussi que Xavier
Bertrand austique encore quelques
ambitions et que c'est un nouvel
formation nous France et Xavier est
toujours adhérent d'elle donc voilà nous
ce qui nous intéresse en tout cas dans
la majorité présidentielle et notamment
à horizon où il n'y aura pas de primaire
c'est de continuer à travailler est-ce
que ce sera Édouard Philippe parce que
je l'espère nous continuons à travailler
et notamment non pas sur la forme mais
sur le fond je crois c'est ce
qu'attendent les Français aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup merci à vous d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin la ligne de
Ouest-France Stéphane c'est la Chine
elle a une de westrance en Chine une
contestation inédite depuis 30 ans merci
beaucoup Stéphane Garcia on passe au
club d'État